1972 est né du livre valence est la
première ville à réagir dans une
direction particulière celle de
l'enfance en organisant une semaine de
manifestations destinées aux jeunes
lecteurs et à leurs parents la maison
des jeunes et de la culture sert de
cadre vos activités prévues pour cette
semaine à savoir notamment de
représentation théâtrale de présentation
de films et une exposition ou des
montages divers et des livres du monde
entier voisinent avec des travaux
d'enfants les premiers intéressés dans
cette aventure qu'est ce que raconte ce
livre que tu lis beaucoup
parfait
wahou cas là c'est beaucoup ça qu'est ce
que tu aimes dire non hays banque
les bandes dessinées l'histoire de
l'émoi des six compagnons histoires
policières m bien j'aime bien et ces
deux livres de bibliothèque compte en
faire de l'irak
non je sais jamais comment offerte je
vais en chercher la bise à fond bien que
le moment est ce que tu lis chez toi
lundi deux auteurs drômois écrivant pour
l'enfance signer leurs ouvrages à la mjc
à une pierre jean recrue récente mais
déjà célèbre et pleine de promesses et
paul jacques bonzom qui a trente ans de
métier a fait paraître 70 titres et vend
chaque année un million d'exemplaires
c'est le sim noms de la littérature
enfantine poljak bonjour la centaine de
traduction qui jalonnent votre oeuvre de
quoi étonner le néophyte comment
expliquez vous qu'une histoire très
française généralement même très situé
sur le plan régional intéresse un petit
garçon malgache aux japonais et c'est
une question que je me suis posé souvent
moi même et au début j'étais étonné du
nombre de traductions de livres mais je
constate une chose c'est que tous les
enfants du monde se ressemble et
comprenant petits malgaches un petit
suédois et finlandais
il ressemble un petit français et un
amant est-ce que parmi tous les groupes
vous avez créé vous avez un favori le
j'ai toujours n'a toujours un favori
mon favori c'est un enfant un peu
déshérités un ancien élève qui était
complètement chauve et y porter
constamment un béret
je l'aimé beaucoup parce qu'ils se
sentent un peu en état d'infériorité
avec les autres et on leur présente
toujours avec son béret sur la tête
guy bernard ce qui est devenu presque
célèbre il s'appelle de tomber il
s'appelle le temps du une pierre jaune
que vous écrivez des romans
psychologiques au niveau de l'enfant ce
qu'est ce que ça veut dire viens
j'essaie de mettre en scène des enfants
tels que je les connais dans les
aventures vraisemblable
et chemin faisant j'ai c'est de leur
offrir une connaissance d'eux-mêmes et
des têtes que vous écrivez ce que vous
pensez que vous participez à la
formation de générations futures de
lecteurs je pense que tous les auteurs
pour enfants il pense de toute façon
j'étais éducatrice et évidemment je
pense beaucoup
j'ai fait la semaine du livre de
l'enfance aura permis outre ces
rencontres importantes pour les auteurs
comme pour leur public de redéfinir la
démarche pédagogique
enseignants et parents lui devront un
nouvel éclairage de la tâche qui leur
incombe et les enfants un peu de rêve
brusquement solidifier